david how's how's your cognitive
dissonance going from
talking a basically uh marinating your
brain
uh for a couple of days in warren
buffett's value investing and then
taking that marinated brain and searing
it on the grill that is
cryptocurrency how's your brain uh
well one of my wife's uh favorite quotes
that uh she's much much smarter than i
am she's a phd she's
wonderful and does not work in tech it
thinks
not a high benchmark but continue yeah
not a high benchmark
uh one of her favorite quotes is uh the
true hallmark of intelligence is uh the
ability to hold two conflicting
ideas in your head at the same time so
okay i just you know i've been having
that drilled into me for about 15 years
now
which part of warren buffett's argument
do you think is strongest charlie
munger's argument is strongest and that
you take away from that side of the
argument
and then we'll go to which side uh do we
think they're most wrong argument
uh their arguments against crypto or
parts of their philosophy in general
that i like yes
yes thanks both their general world view
let's take their world view which
includes crypto and value investing
let's take their entire world view and
where you think they're right
and where you think they might have a
blind spot if any oh great
uh well we just wrapped up recording our
finale part three last night
so i'm very okay so warren's whole thing
that you hear him say
over and over and over again all the
time never bet against america you know
america's
future okay and for his life that was
the case he was born in 1930
right after uh the stock market crash
and you know just like
his life has been america up and to the
right
and he has been a master at taking the
long
view on that whatever's gonna happen in
any given year
any given cycle just like we saw in
crypto here you know like it's all noise
in the long run uh and you believe that
i belie for your lifetime view i'm not
sure it's necessarily
america is the domain that it applies to
anymore uh it may
it may not i don't have a view one way
or the other in that the market is
bigger than america but american
exceptionalism will continue
do you believe it will continue through
our lifetime i think it applies
to the internet obviously this is the
rosenthal doctrine yeah
not never been bet against america but
never bet against the internet
exactly ah oh i like that i like that i
would agree with
both of those statements ben when you
look at
warren buffett and charlie munger's
worldview life philosophy as you have
marinated in it for three episodes what
is your key takeaway
that you think is absolutely spot on
inspiringly correct
and you cannot get out of your head this
is like built into your
sort of operating system now has
infected your brain
well let me bring it into a poker
analogy so uh
they do investing as an expected value
calculation
where the there's the probability
something will happen and then the
payoff if it does happen
their style of investing index indexes
about as aggressively as you can
towards certainty and so the payoff is
is muted but we're pretty certain
that that will continue to happen for
many years in the future somewhere in
the middle you have tech investing and
if you have early stage tech investing
it skews a little bit more towards
speculating really than investing you
got great people you got a great trend
but there's no
business to analyze really yet um and
then if you keep going
all the way on the other side of the
spectrum you've got crypto and so you
have to be comfortable making the
complete opposite investment philosophy
and it may be a speculation philosophy
where you're saying the probability of
that something happens might be really
low but the payoff will be really really
high so it is just like
it's that one simple ev equation
and then just weighting the different
factors in in dramatic ways
yet your chosen profession is not to run
a mutual fund and put money into disney
and ibm and starbucks jason you gotta
have fun in life
so since you don't look at that sugar
wearing ben
yeah bed's getting a little wild over
here so ben since you don't care about
coffee
disney and cigarettes and you don't pour
your money into those things
you're basically saying their safe
philosophy
is not for ben gilbert
and i certainly don't want it to be a
point in my life yeah see i think that's
actually
a reasonable decision at your age 23
this is a better decision for you right
now you're 22.
what do you what are you doing you're
31.
31. so you want to hit your 1000x
you want that possibility you're not
going to get that possibility buying
disney
or starbucks or apple stock it's not
possible
and frankly to bring us back to
cryptocurrencies i am sympathetic to the
argument that
you can sort of look at bitcoin as it
could grow into steel
gold's market cap and that the idea that
there's still a 10
15 x left in bitcoin uh it's not
investment advice i don't know if this
is going to happen but i'm sympathetic
to that belief and it makes sense to me
it's not crazy it's not crazy there are
other other things
you look at uniswap or some of these
other solana where could still be a
thousand x
um but explain it no to go back to the
audience unit swap and
so i kicked this to david he's deeper
than i am
okay well we uh since we're bringing up
a thousand x's let's
i can't let that one just fall on the
cutting room floor
and of course like the you gotta do the
expected value thing like you have to
assign your own very low probability
versus bitcoin's much
more sort of muted reasonable
probability right the idea that
all of the people who have taken on
bitcoin as religion
and as a store of value would all
in some short period of time say you
know what i do i no longer believe
what i believe for the last ten years
five years three years with
a 10 bed of my net worth the fact that
they would all unravel that
would be hard to believe yeah they would
go down
i think it's so often in investing the
right answer is you don't know what the
future holds
it's uncertain and so you should do both
like right um
but yeah no uh you swap and solano are
two
different examples of i think where a
lot of the innovation is happening right
now so uniswap
is a um uh automated market maker
liquidity pool uh that allows you so
like when you trade like
i just experienced this the a couple
weeks ago i
sold some um i sold some stock
uh in my brokerage at vanguard uh
because i wanted to i was transferring
over to my 401k
uh doing the sep ira plan move so i was
just liquidating some stock from my
brokerage account wanted to get it into
my
ira account uh it took five days
from the time i put the sell order into
my brokerage account to that i could buy
in my separate account even though all
at vanguard
same securities i don't want all i want
to do is transfer ownership
that's ridiculous and that happens
because you gotta have counterparties on
the other side of your trade and then it
takes three days for the trades to sell
you know all this from
you know robin hood uh uniswap is an
automated
liquidity pool uh market maker all just
happens instantaneously all
decentralized
you know there are no counterparties i
mean it's all within the pool all done
through smart contracts
on ethereum awesome so
let's explain that in plain english you
you own a bitcoin
it's worth 38 000 you say
you know what i don't want to be in
bitcoin anymore i want
to have more risk and fun owning doge
and
ethereum so i want to swap my bitcoin
for 50 doge and 50
ethereum my normal course of events
would be to sell
my bitcoin on my coinbase account or
whatever you use
robinhood etc pay a bunch of fees which
would be not de minimis
wait and then go buy doge
and ethereum at whatever the market rate
is and pay another fee correct
meanwhile how is unit market makers
in what you described they're market
makers on the other sides of those
transactions that are profiting off of
your
you know your order flow ascendant order
flow whatever like
it's a service that they're providing to
the market
with unislop swap and other
decentralized market makers
they're just liquidity pools and then
anybody you me no matter how much
uh of any one token we have we could
have a lot we could have a little
whatever
we can put our our tokens into
the liquidity pool and then we can get
paid for it just like whoever's
providing liquidity and the markets
are getting paid uh and it'll all happen
instantaneously and it's all
decentralized so i put
my one bitcoin into uniswap they now
take ownership of that they have
custodian of my one bitcoin
and then other people get to do what
with
it that's a good question i don't know
i'm not deep enough to know whether
custodial ownership
actually transfers or not i would assume
to some
some rights do uh but
um but yeah like if you're like yeah i'm
gonna hold this bitcoin i'm not gonna do
anything with it i'll just stick it into
this liquidity pool
and then you're gonna get a yield on
that huh
i suddenly feel like michael che and
like uh colin jost asking what asking
elon what doge
is and it's like
it but you got to be loving life that
pandemic is essentially over
uh yes at least you are traveling you're
seeing i'm
living my best life by design i am out
the tiger
has left the building like i literally
was like this tiger and like
i pushed the gate with my nose by
accident and it kind of creaked open and
then i put my paw out and i was like
touching the ground
like wait a second i'm out is somebody
gonna hit me with the electric prod and
then i'm like
i run back in and then i came back out a
little bit more and then i was like oh
[ __ ]
i'm i'm running i just bolted the heck
out of the cage and i am
i am going i'm literally in new york
went to the knicks game
sunday went to the nets game last night
going to the next game fifth row tonight
going to raul's monday night having the
stakeholder
you know full contact on you know
full contact on twitter just walking
over the brooklyn bridge of manhattan
bridge multiple times drinking iced
coffee just
living my best life going back to austin
hitting miami
i am done with the pandemic 100
like i am done how are you guys doing
with your
post-pandemic lives i'm curious now that
we're catching up
i'm feeling similarly i mean you're
vaccinating obviously
yeah yeah i'm a month in or something um
and you know there's still risk but it's
i think this
has really opened my eyes to relative
risk in a way that
i don't think i used to think enough
about like
not doing stuff has a downside too and
that downside might be
way way higher than the idea example um
okay so i don't know if these
percentages are right but let's say
the percentage of me going out in the
world including indoor dining and
let's even take an extreme example like
an indoor cycling class
um the probability of me getting you
know life-altering
or serious covet at this point has to be
similar to me like driving my car to
work every day for some period of time
certainly there's something
certainly less you know certain like
certainly less right so if i'm willing
to take those risks
in my life to date shouldn't i be
willing to
take this risk of living my life and
what is the risk
of not living my life at this point that
has a
immensely high uh depression suffering
anxiety doom scrolling at 4 4am and
being a caged tiger
tigers and so yeah to be in the jungle
absolutely and
that's your shirt today you are a tiger
in the jungle
yeah look at that shirt he's gone bug
wild i mean are you gonna dye your hair
ben what's going on
i mean it's already close to rosenthal
length so you've gone full rosenthal
but are you gonna die let me ask you
this have you considered i considered
dying my hair blue
coming out of the pandemic i've always
wanted to have blue hair and i was like
i'm kind of thinking about my friend i'm
kind of thinking about it i think it
would be ridiculous
and i think what do you if you were
gonna dye your hair what color would you
go ben
so i was one of those kids in middle
school that did blonde tips
like the frosted frosted tips i had i
had the wave
in the front that would just the wave
was blonde for a little bit
wow i was frosted so awake because i
never thought to do it to my hair though
keep going
uh so anything that i do i would have to
make sure resembled nothing like that
uh ever can we get a photo of that
can we get a photo with highlights i'll
see what i can do
all right so now back to the warren
buffett philosophy i really like what
you guys have taken
from from from them now
the criticism from the crypto side is
these people are
old and whatever lessons they learned
are wrong
is there anything is there anything
david i mean
it's correct that they're very old but
do you think even warren would agree
with you there i mean there's
i mean collectively are they a hundred
and eighty i mean one's nine
charlie numbers 97 warren is 91.
okay so if you add those two numbers up
you're minusing
13 there are 187 combined
i mean dang we should all be so lucky
so i wonder david
do you think their historical
perspective you know to the crypto
people saying don't listen to old stirs
knowing what you know now do you think
that that criticism of their wisdom
is not applicable going forward
are you more convinced of that or you're
more convinced that it's applicable
uh more convinced it's not applicable of
two takes on this
wow i could be wrong but like i've seen
them talk about
i don't think they've actually dug into
anything in crypto
like you know their arguments against
bitcoin you know like you could take it
or leave it
i don't personally agree with it like i
don't think i think bitcoin is valuable
like et cetera but like
they haven't dug into anything beyond
that like they just don't engage uh
so i think it's hard to take their
criticism seriously when you're like
dude you guys haven't done that okay
now what about their philosophical
advice
so um and their outlook on our buddy
value investing our buddy andrew marks
uh
at tqventures uh who's awesome uh we
talked about this in the episode he
uh he's known warren and charlie like
most most of his whole life
uh his dad's howard mark's the uh yeah
you know uh
and studied them he's good and his take
on this
is like look warren is is and was the
world's greatest uh he calls it status
quo
investor as long as the future is mostly
gonna look like the present
nobody is better than warren at
handicapping probabilities valuations
making investments
et cetera et cetera and track record
which it did until like 1995. honestly
like you look from
1950 to 1995 a lot of stuff changed but
nowhere near
the rate that the world reorganizes
itself on a
five-year and one-year basis now yeah
and there's this great
moment in 97 at the sun valley the allen
company conference yeah sure
[Music]
so this panel on stage with the uh
robert roberto goyzetta
the ceo of coke uh warren buffett
and bill gates yeah and on this panel
gates is like he like mortally offends
uh roberto roberto never talks to him
again for the rest of his life
where he's like basically he basically
says like coca-cola could be run by a
ham sandwich like
which is a warren line that he borrows
it's a freaking true
uh wow and he's like versus microsoft
like
it's dynamic things are changing like
i'm gonna have to retire because by the
time i'm six i'm your age
i'm not gonna be able to run microsoft
because things change too fast
wow uh and that's the world we live in
today
well and well actually though in
fairness coca-cola and the drinking of
soda might have taken three decades has
gotten absolutely pummeled and like yeah
they're in the water i mean they're
still in the liquid business i guess
arguably liquid in bottles is still
their business but you know it's
definitely not
soda i'm not excited to buy coke stock
yeah coke stop was a really high
performer yeah i guess you have to roll
the punches okay ben just wrapping up
here
uh anything in their philosophy that
sticks with you in a deep way um
i'm listening to a walk down wall street
um
right now random walk down wall street a
random walk down wall street right now
i'm just
i am so enamored with these fraud
moments
it's just like z cleaners and all of
these different like chicken stands
going public it's literally like the
worst of spacks combined with the worst
of crypto combined with theranos
and you're like this happened in the 60s
they added
pronix to a name of a company and it
went from four times
you know uh an ebitda multiple to 16.
i'm like hmm
where have i heard that before oh yeah
adding.com oh no adding crypto
it's like it's the same movie over and
over again some trend happens the
charlatans
come in it's a real trend and they just
take suckers money from it bet anything
you want to close with there
yeah i think the biggest thing that's
left an impact on me
and of course the world has changed and
i i believe that
you need a different style of investing
today to
to deal with um the fact that the world
completely changed five ten years from
now underneath your feet
but their notion of
intense preparation to be ready when the
moment comes to move quickly
i don't think i fully understood and
appreciated that before
the way that they were able to take some
of these really big positions in
companies that just you know knocked
their socks off
was because they spent years
understanding the sector understanding
that business and they said
if it ever got to this price like let's
say someone tried to buy them and then
backed out and then the stock pummeled
they were always there and could make a
decision in an hour
because of how prepared they were wow
and i think it's that level of
um of sort of preparation and sort of
itemizing
opportunities if at the right price they
ever came along to be able to move
quickly that's a powerful concept
and of course the epic moment was 2008
when they bought 5 billion worth
of preferred shares in goldman sachs
way better on their b of a deal than on
uh goldman
well the goldman i think um it uh
they redeemed them uh earning
they got about eight billion back on the
five billion invested because they made
three billion
in profit that's incredible 3.7 billion
i mean
you know here's the thing you know when
we talk we talk about multiples because
we're investing at such small
you know implied we're betting against
long odds small bets and we we need 100
x
but when you're putting a big number to
work and you get a big number back even
if it's not 2x
it's still a lot of capital in a short
period of time that was a fixed income
that was that was not common equity it
was a preferred it was essentially debt
so low risk high return
that was a great move all right before
we move on to
james bond uh i'll leave you with this
incredible quote
uh which i love from warren buffett i
try to invest in businesses that are so
wonderful that an idiot can run them
because sooner or later one will
this is the ham sandwich idea it's the
ham sandwich idea
well i mean i i have i have been
thinking about this myself and
i if i could take like i would love for
there to be a vehicle and somebody
please email me if this exists in the
world
as i liquidate and get tech stocks is
there a way i know there are these
like um ways to transfer shares almost
like this unit swap like into pools and
exchange trades i just want somebody to
create
um a way for me to just take a
percentage of my net worth
and just hit a dial and put it into
disney
and amazon or whatever you know like
just these are three things that i
believe will exist and be
bigger when my kids grow up i just want
to move
a percentage of my net worth every year
into a disney stock
um i guess i the problem is like i i'm
struggling with this concept of paying
all this capital gains and then buying
another share
versus keeping tech stocks that are high
growth you know like if you own square
like an uber and robin hood and calm or
whatever
shopify like okay this is a great run
it's going to keep going but i would
really like to own some disney too
yeah that sold apple and made three
million dollars on their investment
total or six million
dollars you know yeah
well this is not investment advice but
couldn't you um couldn't you borrow
against your
stock and then do it that way i don't
think you're
i mean i think borrowing against stock
and then buying other stock
is the big no-no i think they give you
like a huge warning
like i i'm sure people do it but i think
there's like a big warning like
if you're taking margin to get stock
please don't buy stock
you